[Music]
good evening
[Music]
oh wait you're just a civilian now
mr james ford general ryan is requesting
your
inimitable counsel no
he's offered to reinstate you
[Music]
from the top four hours ago the crew the
vander made first contact
stay there
they believe we're hostile
in the event of first contact humanity
must strike first
to ensure the continued survival
of our species operation cosmic sin
is now a go but there
is a space gate they can bring their
army here
what's the status of the cube if we want
to launch the cue bomb
we need to get into orbit suits up
that's something huh we didn't know
whether to burn it we put in a museum
i'm sure they said the same thing about
me
if we leave that door open we're gonna
charge in
we can make
what we do here is easy
the hard part is living with it
the world has a way of changing but
there's one thing
that always stays the same you miss the
old life
deal
[Music]
crank it all the way up
[Music]
you're going on a journey
all you have to do is follow my voice
so this is the famous suicide squad
antonio soprano
welcome to the space jam
[Music]
venus and serena go shake up this world
the streets were made of music
just listen
to me
how can we help it's an invitation
it's immortal combat it's a little
thanks jimmy
no one likes to show off unless they're
showing off as dope as
[Music]
in theaters and on hbo max
this is our only chance
we have to take
we need kong the world needs him
to stop what's coming
in this child she's the only one he'll
communicate with
i knew that they had a bond she had
nowhere to go
so i made a promise to protect her
and i think that in some way khan did
the same
[Music]
that's godzilla
these are dangerous times godzilla's out
there and he's hurting people and we
don't
know why there's something provoking him
that we're not seeing here
by the same opinion the myths are
real yeah there was a war
and they're the last ones standing for
greatness to no one
are we there yet this beach it's
beautiful
my swimsuit is hurting they do look
small come on let's play hide and seek
have you seen my children mom i'm right
here
he was six years old this morning oh no
mom i'm scared there's something wrong
with this beach we were chosen for a
reason
what's happening i don't know i can't
think
oh only in theaters this summer all
right guys
remember what we're looking for and
don't trust
anyone
hey baby where are your parents
hey uh who's baby what
really a con baby
[Music]
impressive we could use someone like you
let's catch you up my name is raya
our lands have been at war for as long
as we can remember
our people never see eye to eye
my daughter i believe our people can
come together again
but someone has to take the first step
now in order to restore peace
we must find the last dragon i wish to
join this
fellowship of hickory
let's go we'll have to watch our backs
we're not the only ones looking
six years of searching please let this
be it
we really need your help ah i'm gonna be
real with you i'm not like the best
dragon have you ever done like a group
project but there's like that one kid
who didn't pitch in as much but
still ended up with the same grave uh
we're doomed
you and the dragon are coming with me
hmm my sword here says we're not
the world's broken
you can't trust anyone
maybe it's broken because you don't
trust anyone
you just have to take the first step
i just shave change dragons can do that
look how close my butt is to my head
it's gonna make digestion so much faster
in theaters or ordered on disney plus
with premier access
march 5th
they've taken control of most of europe
and russia
merciful heaven and invasion that's not
all mr president
i take it that's where your big idea
comes in let me introduce you the team
we said we would end this war
too many people have died
we can stop this
we need to utilize every meta human we
can
who've you got there wonder woman i'm
from the future
it's not impossible
are you ready to end this war i thought
you'd never ask then welcome to the team
if this goes haywire blame the new guy
turns out the nazis are launching a
surprise attack then we stop them
mother of god
a kid you ain't seen nothing yet
hello
maria wolf your father is no longer of
use to us
you have something we want
do you think this is a game the way we
should
sorry we're out of time
i've kept everything you can do hidden
hoping to prevent them from finding you
what am i
everything you need to know is
wake up
[Music]
just discovered that i may have a son
here in this land how much child support
is she getting from the king pays no
child support no child support for 30
years and you came back
use a
he's supposed to be like the prince of
wakanda
is a fictional place not everybody so
munda is a very
real nation i don't need no handouts
wait a minute okay
[Applause]
resentence
and my mom's and his moms
children this is your brother hey kwai
i'm sorry i slept with your man this
happened before we even met
it's not like you're the first man i've
ever been with
what did you just say about the other
men coming to america now he's coming to
me
i always thought that mika was going to
be queen a woman isn't allowed to lose
amunda it's the law
did it ever occur to you that megan
wanted to be your heir
would you dare banish me from my own
bedroom
[Applause]
how are you doing i'm getting it from
everywhere
i am upset in my family
be strong and general izzy would love
nothing more than to take over someone
raise it higher
i must admit your style is far into my
kingdom but it's impressive
that's right there you go let me hear
you say hey ho hey ho
no don't do that that's my mother oh
don't you say that no not to his mother
almost ready to become a prince almost
it is time
ceremonial circumcision queen's power
royals
mercedes ain't gonna sharpen you too
nephew
mr president it's extremely serious
there's been a massive earthquake in
northeastern japan today
the fukushima daiichi nuclear power
plant is in critical condition
there's a make a tsunami warning
if the power isn't restored core decay
meltdown
to prevent that it's necessary to
release some pressure through this
pipeline sir
someone must go inside the contaminated
reactor building
the radiation is high we'll choose he'll
go
if you're willing to volunteer you
should raise your hand
i'll go meet you sir me too i can't
those workers are risking their life
decide now
it could burst at any second
[Music]
i'll stay to save my hometown even if i
have to die
[Music]
five six
[Music]
i met this girl hi hi uh i'm mark
dude i saw you last night you didn't
tell me anything about a girl this is
gonna sound really strange
i was wondering are you experiencing any
kind of temporal anomaly
listen we're stuck in a time loop you me
everybody same day repeating over and
over again like in groundhog day and
edge of tomorrow except only me and this
girl margaret know about it but you
don't remember any of this because your
brain keeps getting erased
oh so what have you brought to with
infinite time oh you know like
solving crimes and teaching myself how
to drive
i thought so you're into her well like
i'm not not
into her you ever wish today happened on
a different day
just hoping we could talk about your
future besides who knows what they want
to do when they're 17.
i do aerospace engineer specifically a
nasa mission specialist
wait like an astronaut because that's
cool that's like uh
most of life is just junk and then
there's these moments and all the
randomness turns into something perfect
that is
disturbingly inspirational what if we
found them all all the perfect things
we could collect them like partners
oh yeah okay tell your secret
i don't have to pretend
[Music]
what is this oh i dropped him
he made a map of us
i should go
[Applause]
we could get out of it are you really in
that much of a hurry
you don't actually think that this is
living do you we have all the time in
the world
this is not time time is the stuff that
when you spend it you don't get it back
i thought everything was perfect but
there's more to the story
[Music]
i thought we'd have so much more time
[Music]
is
[Music]
i love my life i love you so much gary
i'll never forget the day we met hello
little snail what's your name
gary huh do you want to be friends
me too gary
i'm home gary bear
gary oh gary have you seen gary no
nope nope gary's been
[Music]
get ready for the ultimate rescue
in mission all-new spongebob movie this
is going to be like
one of those bloody movies
with aquafina you're fired danny trejo
snoop dogg no surprise bob tiffany
seriously folks i'm floundering up here
and keanu reeves call me sage i'm made
out of sage and i am a sage
so it works out pretty well see how the
gang all met
little dude and experience spongebob's
biggest adventure ever
ew
sorry saves them
[Applause]
the all-new spongebob movie sponge on
the run premiering march 4th rented from
these digital stores
also streaming on paramount plus
why do you keep closing your laptop
every time i walk by
you look stressed
[Music]
work's been uh crazy
i've always wanted to change the world
how
amazon is for drugs
but you can't buy drugs on the internet
what if you could
using bitcoin i just made 75 grand
in the last 90 minutes baby that's 1.2
million
a day
this guy's the first millennial gangster
you're gonna crack this the
old-fashioned way ancient potent
everything they know they learned off a
screen
not staring down the barrel of a gun
experience matters oh
when you snatch him up send me a fax
the dark net something special came in
the mail
game is changing it's going to be every
suburb in america
this website needs to be shut down
immediately
i'm the one's going to bring this brick
down
you crossed this line ain't no going
back
you're getting obsessive
we get him on conspiracy to commit
murder
this thing is going to outlive all of us
when i started working at marvel i asked
stanley
how do you create the perfect marvel
character he said imagine spider-man
it's just a red and blue suit jumping
off a building but tell me who he is
tell me what his problems are and now
when he flies off that building
we're in that suit
every moment along the way the superhero
has offered us a language to think about
our personal identities
who are you who do you want to be
my father did not like bullies comic
books
for the vehicle to protect people
what a powerful image the black panther
story is
this idea of an untouched black space it
brought me to tears almost
instantaneously
it wasn't pretend to me it was real it
was like you can tell
stories about yourself i transformed
into the most powerful entity in the
hip-hop universe
there was a time when asian people and
comics were colored yellow i would just
say hey
maybe it's time we stopped doing that
women are drawn with male marks of
toughness
being a woman is different than that the
question is what you do from those
mistakes you learn from them
i had no idea that i was the first
african-american writer in modern comics
she is just as good as the boys being a
gay youth
coming to a great place to hide for the
first time we kind of felt like we were
part of the story
we developed a completely new voice i
love it
you look at any great marvel story i
don't care who the character is
what the team is it's always a great
story about the person
behind the mask
you know what we wouldn't have found we
would have stayed on the trail
what is
the that people here know but don't talk
about except in whispers
anyone who goes up there what is this
place
they don't come back
descendants of these people are still
living up there on the mountain
many moons ago a nameless evil was
imprisoned in a place
far beyond reach hurry up
if he were ever to be released it would
spell
certain doom for
is this yours
[Music]
whoever wields it is able to command me
go over there
and wait first to come back good morning
you will suffer an eternity for this
mom dad i want you to meet psycho gorman
or pg for short i will bathe in your
blood
don't worry be worried
he's gonna kill everybody not unless i
tell him
[Music]
what did you three maniacs get up to um
this is getting a little
come to an weird she will enslave the
galaxy into endless servitude
kill him cool
the ultimate evil has awoken
[Music]
there's a new god in town and his name
psycho gorman
it was nice meeting you it would be
nicer if you were dead
all right bye
[Music]
you